le prix du jury elle n'est pas spécial
mais extrêmement spéciale c'est le prix
du jury
je vous demande d'accueillir l'acteur
britannique gary oldman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sera difficile de faire aussi bien
que roberto benigni et déçoit on entre
alors c'est un immense honneur c'est un
privilège d'avoir été agréé invité ici
au festival de cannes qui est sans
l'ombre d'un doute le meilleur ski val
du fil je serais passé à côté de
l'occasion incroyable de travailler avec
cate blanchett
madame le président donc qui est
l'heureux lauréat du prix du jury
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci infiniment pour ce prix inouïe
c'est une chance énorme pour un film qui
est un petit film qu'on a fait à la
maison en famille mais pendant que je
fête du cinéma avec vous je ne peux pas
ne pas penser à une petite fille qui
s'appelle side qui a joué le rôle de
saab dans le film qui joue le rôle de la
soeur de zen dans le film est là
aujourd'hui elle a probablement passé
toute sa journée debout sous le soleil
le visage collé contre les vitres des
voitures a essayé de se défendre comme
elle peut contre les insultes contre les
humiliations des uns et des autres elle
a probablement essayé de ruse et comme
elle peut avec sa sagesse de petite
fille de 12 ans qu'elle a appris à
l'école de la rue ruser pour ne pas se
faire abuser
et puis allez probablement rentrer chez
elle elle a fait la vaisselle elle à
l'âge et à laver le linge de à toute sa
famille ses frères et soeurs elle a
probablement préparé à manger à ses
frères et soeurs et puis elle s'est
endormie en rêvant qu'un jour elle
pourra aller à l'école comme tous les
enfants de la terre je vous dis cela
parce que je sais que à nous tous ici
présents on peut changer quelque chose
je crois profondément au pouvoir du
cinéma le cinéma n'est pas seulement
fait pour divertir pour faire rêver il
est aussi fait pour faire réfléchir pour
montrer l'invisible pour dire ce qu'on
peut pas dire on peut plus continuer à
tourner le dos est restée aveugle à la
souffrance de ces enfants qui se
débattent comme ils peuvent
dans ce capharnaüm qui est devenu le
monde je ne sais pas quelle est la
solution
moi même je ne l'est pas avec toute ma
bonne volonté je n'ai pas réussi à
sauver sidra de la rue et je ne sais pas
quel va être le destin de zen non plus
quand il rentrera chez lui ni celui de
ses frères et soeurs ni celui de la
petite syrienne dans le film my soul
mais je voudrais vous inviter à
réfléchir parce que l'enfance mal aimée
est à la base du mal dans le monde
je voudrais qu'on réfléchisse ensemble
pour trouver une solution
ce film ce prix je voudrais le dd en
premier à tous mes acteurs tous qui ne
sont pas réellement des acteurs qui
m'ont ouvert le coeur qui m'ont ouvert
leur vie qui m'ont tout donné qui ont
décidé de me faire confiance et de me
raconter leurs peines et leurs
souffrances dans ce monde je voudrais
aussi le dédier à ma deuxième famille
mes soldats mon équipe je vous aime tous
merci d'avoir décidé de mémé de me
porter malgré toutes les circonstances
merci d'avoir décidé de me suivre dans
cette folle aventure malgré tout je
voudrais aussi remercier mes
distributeurs et producteurs
tous ces genres entre gardiens qui ont
décidé aussi de mémé de me porter malgré
tout je voudrais cd dédié aussi à ma
famille
mes parents à mes enfants mais rooney
walid à mon mari mon bon musicien et qui
est maintenant devenu mambo producteurs
je voudrais aussi le dédier à mon pays
qui malgré tout ce qu'on lui reproche
ses débats comme il peut et malgré tout
ce qu'on lui reproche a quand même
accueilli le plus grand nombre de
réfugiés dans le monde
[Applaudissements]
même temps même quand il n'a pas les
moyens de subvenir aux besoins de sa
propre population
et puis en dernier je voudrais dire un
petit truc à ma petite soeur caroline
avec qui j'ai rêvé de cinéma toute ma
vie kucka wild et on a préparé les
acteurs
vous sélectionnez un certain regard la
cinéaste libanaise fait son entrée dans
la compétition cannoise par ce petit
jury avec un film qui a vu nombre de
festivals du disque la rocade à beyrouth
a fait diversion de duisans qui intente
un procès à ses parents pour l'avoir mis
au monde
il est si ensuite tragiquement
et puis avec
[Applaudissements]
merci madame